Continue working on your project or re-open the one context project from the last video.
At this stage, you see the architectural model in the scene and nothing else except for a generic ground and a background.
We'll be setting this project in France, in Paris to be precise.
Under Populate in the Dock, choose the Urban panel.
If you zoom out, you'll notice that they are viewing an area of Paris, France.
Twinmotion was originally developed in France, so this is a bit of an homage to that.
This spot will work for us, but you can obviously pick a spot anywhere in the world using the map or the search box.
Zoom on an area around the Ile de la Cité where the famous Notre Dame Basilica is set, and grab that area by clicking the Download button.
This will take a moment as the system fetches information from OpenStreetMap and places the data around your project.
Once done, look at the scene graph and note how the project and the surroundings are set under two different containers for easier selection.
This means you can easily control the visibility of the environment and the architectural project separately.
Hierarchies are preserved, which means that you can select the top parents to adjust and place assemblies appropriately.
Select and move a few of these trees to make place for the project.
Place the project appropriately.
There are a few other things that you can do.
For example, the current background shows a city that looks more North American than European.
You can change that in the Ambient panel, under the Horizon section.
Let's use a European city instead. You can also adjust the rotation as you see fit.
Since we're dealing with global adjustments, let's set the time of day to about 4.30pm, and the North offset to about 65 degrees.
As a bonus, and since we are on an island, let's bring some water in.
In the scene graph, make sure to hide the generic starting ground.
In the Ambience panel, enable Ocean mode.
Set the height so that it is below the ground. Minus 100cm should be enough.
Choose a water aspect that you like.
I admit I like the default Clear River best, so I'll keep that one.
Save your work. Next, we work on embellishing the architectural project with the help of ready-made materials.